joining us this morning with me hope
fewer audio problems at the transport
secretary grant chaps mr shaps good to
see you this morning um
somewhat appropriate that we come off
the back of the gdp figures and a week
of big announcements
yours yesterday certainly one that
people are hoping will give a shot in
the arm to the economy just just take us
through the thinking
uh behind that which you announced
yesterday particularly as regards the
the the lack of requirement for people
coming back double vaccinated
from ambulance company countries to
isolate
yeah well that's right i mean up until
now if you've gone to an amber this
country
uh we'll start we said you shouldn't be
going there for holidays but you also
had to come back and you had to
quarantine or self-isolate what we did
yesterday on the basis of the fact that
we now have
such a large proportion of uh of people
um fully vaccinated it said if you have
been fully vaccinated
then you can essentially travel from the
19th of july
to an ambulance country without needing
to come back and quarantine you'll still
need to come back and take a day two
pcr test um but that will of course open
up
large number of countries which fall
into that amber category by far the
biggest group
between the red amber and green so good
news for people who are
looking forward to maybe seeing loved
ones abroad or even catching some sun
but what though of of loved ones who who
live abroad and come back here as you
say you're talking about people who are
who are fully vaccinated but fully
vaccinated
via the nhs i think at the moment there
are around about 30 countries that
accept
our certification why won't we accept
anyone else's
well that would be phase two of it and
something we're very actively working on
at the moment of course with the uk
vaccination program
we're able to you're able to demonstrate
your vaccine status very easily the
full nhs app that's not the covert app i
should
point out is the regular nhs app app
contains your
record for your uh vaccines so once
you've been fully vaccinated it
effectively gives you a certificate
which you can show on screen or download
so it's easy for us to be able to use
that in order to demonstrate the status
for
somebody returning home uh that's the
first stage
the next thing is to be able to
recognize uh apps from
other countries or certification from
other countries easier done from some
places like
the eu where they have a digital um app
coming along
uh than it is in the united states where
they have i think 50 different systems
one for each state
largely paper based so there's some
complexities to work through there
but this is phase one and we hope to
follow it up quickly
with double vaccinated people from other
countries coming here
can you put some sort of time frame on
that because clearly
a lot of people are looking forward to
your announcement yesterday they may
well have some time off coming in this
summer there are an awful lot of expat
brits wanting to come back to the united
kingdom
to see their family do you think you're
going to be able to have this done what
next couple of weeks next couple of
months
by the end of the summer yeah so i mean
first of all this announcement kicks in
from the 19th of july for anyone who's
been vaccinated in the uk and then
secondly we're actively working on this
issue of
um how to accept uh vaccinations from
other people obviously we look at
whether they are uh world health
organizations certified and like
and i would think in terms of time scale
in the next couple of weeks i'll be able
to come forward and say more about other
locations in the world
do you understand though the frustration
of of expatriate brits
for example living in italy this weekend
we're going to see around about a
thousand
italian fans coming to this country to
watch the football
and then heading straight back home
afterwards
there will be thousands of people
looking at that and saying well why
can't we do the same
people who perhaps haven't seen their
families for the best part of a year and
a half
yeah yeah no i mean look we want to be
able to open that up for people and
actively working on it i should say with
the with the football um
they come to a specific location they're
taking direct to the football
uh they leave again 12 hours later there
isn't
any they're unable to travel anywhere
else et cetera it's a very restricted
um program but nonetheless i'm going to
take the point that we do want to
get this done part part of the issue of
course is um elsewhere
the level of fully vaccinated people
tends not to be at the levels that we've
got in the uk
because we got on with our vaccination
program so much faster
so you know there aren't as many fully
vaccinated people
for example from europe to come here but
nonetheless we are working on it we do
want to get
this part of it resolved as well i
thought it was important with this phase
one
section you know people who've been
vaccinated in the uk
to get that information out there as
soon as we were ready to make the
announcement which is why i did that
yesterday
but i said we'll follow up with phase
two for people coming the other way
as soon as we can just explain as well
if you can uh minister the
the rationale for for asking for a pcr
test
from children as young as five six years
of age
yeah so first of all i should point out
the um
children 18 year olds and under oh
under 18 of course children will be able
to follow the same rules
regardless of whether they've been
double vaccinating of course the answer
is they won't have been double
vaccinated because currently
the joint committee on vaccines and
immunization have not recommended yet
vaccinating um children and we're
waiting for them to opine on it
so we thought it was right and proper
because they can't be vaccinated
to allow them to adhere to the same
rules but we must of course make sure
that we've got
protection uh for you know everybody in
the united kingdom in place
and a pcr test remains the best way to
do that and it does mean that we're able
to then
uh keep a very close eye on those
variants of concern
which are of course the thing that we
are most worried about now we don't want
to put
the country at risk and and that could
be carried by uh
a child as well so that's the reason why
we're doing it and this is the reason
why everybody will still have to take a
pcr test on day two
when they return in indeed you mentioned
a couple of minutes ago the
the the the nhs uh covered 19 app and
you'll have seen you'll have
i'm presuming actually i've had
conversations about this with with
people in your own department about the
concerns that
when we get into this summer and we see
as the health secretary outlined cases
perhaps running as high as a hundred
thousand new hundred thousand new
cases a day perhaps even higher than
that that we are going to be in a
position where we are seeing potentially
millions of people
and certainly not the majority of them
with covert 19 but millions of people
being forced
to self-isolate what action is being
taken on the app at the moment
yeah that's right i take advice on this
or i we take advice on this from
um the medical um experts and you know
as things like
um the the the overall nationwide levels
for
things like uh the the amount of
distance that you need to keep the
social distancing and other rules
are looked at so will we look at the way
that the app
performs with regard to what are now the
new standards uh being in place so
always keep a very close eye
on those sort of things i i did um speak
to the health secretary about it
yesterday
he's very aware of this and we'll keep
it under constant review because
we want the app to be a useful um tool
in our armory
uh to make sure that we're all able to
uh be aware of and ultimately defeat the
coronavirus and we want it to keep
continue to work in that way
yep so sorry to interrupt mr we're just
a bit pushed for time but but people are
deleting the app as we speak people are
switching off the contact tracing aspect
of it it is fine that
there will be some tinkering we're told
that it will be less sensitive
uh in future but you know if people have
deleted it from their phone they're
unlikely to be putting it back on it
just feels like we might have missed the
boat in this one
that's not actually the evidence by the
way we're still seeing lots of people
downloading the
um app i've encouraged people to do so
as to say we'll keep the
sensitivity of it under review to align
with the new
um recommendations that come in
guidelines to come in on the 19th of
july so we'll continue to do that it is
very useful tool in the army and no one
wants to get
long covered no one wants to get covered
and pass it on somebody who becomes
seriously ill or worse dies so it's in
all our interest to carry on
using every tool that we've got to
defeat coronavirus
and the the app will remain an important
part of
of of our armory to do that and we
encourage people to carry on using it in
the same way as we encourage people to
uh keep applying common sense you know
all the things we know about better
outside than indoors and all the rest of
it and the apps is another
part of that uh of that armory
i do i do want to finish off our
discussion this morning if i can
transport secretary
on your brief and about public transport
over the past couple of days you will
have seen
a number of groups that are interested
you know perhaps representing those who
are
immunosuppressed representing people who
were in the vulnerable category before
the removal of the removal of the
mandating of mass on public transport
is petrifying vulnerable people up and
down the country
what would your advice be to those that
have to travel by public transport who
fall into that category
would you simply say that they should
travel off peak
yeah for start we'll still be issuing
guidelines and
as with everything to do with
coronavirus similar to the conversation
we're just having
um we've been living with this for a
year and a half now people know
uh the the things to do in order to try
to keep themselves um safe
and it's still sensible to wear a face
covering if you're on a a crowded piece
of transport a crowded tube for example
um but clearly if you're on a train on a
perhaps a long distance
service there's no one else in the
carriage um this is not really
protecting anyone and we're able to now
shift to people using their own common
sense
uh increasingly as we get through the
19th of july
uh and asking people to do that so i
think it's right that we switch these
things
from the law to guidance but nonetheless
that doesn't mean that we're not guiding
people to
to be sensible uh and to think about how
they can protect themselves
and others um but recognizing the fact
that
the majority of adults have now been
double vaccined and of course
reminding people to come forward for
their vaccinations and their final
vaccination if they've had the first one
i can't have a government minister on
the program without at least once
referencing the football coming up on
uh on sunday um i won't ask you for a
prediction for the
for the result but strange reports
circulating this morning about people
pushing
perhaps for a bank holiday on monday if
uh
if england do perhaps allowing people to
come in slightly later
uh for work what do you think well i
wouldn't want to jinx it i think is what
what i'd say we're we're all not in my
lifetime i don't think in yours um
have we been in this position i don't
want to say anything that's going to
make any presumptions at all and good
luck to england on
sunday we'll be right behind you